everybody seems fine there's no panic
the you know the belief in themselves is
still good
simeon sends the 3-2 to left field this
ball's well hit and gone well that's a
good start to the afternoon marcus
simeone with number 17 on the season and
the blue jays lead early one to nothing
it's a quiet swing he just uses his
hands and he gets that barrel to the
back and here's vladimir guerrero junior
ladies swings at the first pitch deep
left center field gone
number 23 on the season for guerrero and
it is two to nothing blue jays so the
blue jay batters say i like that first
pitch fastball and it's a straight one
right down broadway for vladi and he
jumps all over overall an okay season
for mount castle was better last year
but he has been hot the last month or so
could an ops over 900 his last 26 games
the 01.
and a fastball hit high in the air to
center field and deep britchik is back
running out of room and it's gone
straight away center field number 10 on
the season for mount castle and it is
now 2-1
this ballpark can become a launching pad
they can give up its share of home run
so you have to be able to keep the ball
down and keep it out of the air
castle's going to cut that lead in half
four-seam fastball
it's about belt high in the middle of
the plate and he's got plenty of power
to knock it out of here two balls and a
strike on mullins but you gotta show
mullins a lot of respect the way that
he's swinging the bat right now the two
one and the slider hit high in the air
to deep right field and mullins has done
it again
his third home run in two games in the
series and the orioles have tied it at
two that's the pitch that they struck
him out with in the first inning but it
floated back over the middle of the
plate and he's a hot hitter
everything you throw up there he's
hitting ryan castle hit his 10th homer
his first at bat there's a line drive
down the left field line and this one is
out of here
just got out
a laser he hit your one iron jim palmer
well he did
what do they call that the on the tour
the the stinger stinger yeah
well he stung that one hit a fastball
the last time and then here it's a
breaking ball and first homer just a
towering shot to center and then the
laser that's hit well d.j stewart he
hardly left the box he knew he got all
over that
that is a loud one
and suddenly
the orioles really laying some lumber
on alec manoa well they are doing what
usually the blue jays do to other teams
which is just
bludgeon the baseball
[Applause]
franco gets hit
yeah well i'll tell you what kid and
manoa comes charging in
orioles bench coming out
brandon high trying to hold his guys
back now here come the bullpen you know
you just don't want guys getting uh
suspended that's all
back-to-back home runs and then you get
drilled
pretty suspicious brandon high trying to
be a peacemaker well and the only reason
you're out here is you got a young
pitcher that
tell you what you threw them
you know the major league hitters are
getting paid to hit home runs
if you're gonna be bad if you're gonna
throw balls down the middle two skippers
yelling at each other
montoya and hyde having words
i never understood why the bullpens just
didn't have a fight out in left field
let's just meet on center field and
save the space how the umpires are
meeting jim and that conversation is are
they going to issue warnings well there
should be a warning but you know that
but they go both ways well it does oh
yeah
he's been injected well i don't like
this either you can't read much
[Applause]
now did it happen was it the pitch or
something after
nope i think they just thought that he
threw at him so here's ryan mott castle
two big swings for him
there's a shot down the left field line
he has done it again
ryan mount castle with three home runs
the rookie making a loud statement here
today
and the orioles
five hits five homers
last two home runs on breaking balls
this is the curveball
matter is it going to stay fair
out of here
going to hurt
it is indeed guriel to come up and pinch
hit he will bat for jared hoing
lined up the middle backhand wilkerson
one there onto first
wow stevie wilkerson flashing some goal
leather
on a just screaming one hop shot
well i'll tell you what you want to save
somebody's bacon
make this kind of play this is the guy
that couldn't catch a ground ball in
cleveland two down top of the order
cedric mullins he's in this
home run hit parade there's a shot maybe
we got another one way back he's got
another one
cedric mullins leaves the yard
and the hits just keep on coming six
hits
all home runs second of the game for
mullins his fourth in the last two games
and now he has the team lead with 13 on
the season
[Applause]
marcus simeon first pitch swinging
drives it to left field his second home
run of the game the ball is flying at
camden yards it's now eight to four
these players nowadays make it look so
easy
how you turn around a fastball like that
we mentioned harvey's got a big fastball
the best out of the bullpen that the
orioles have to offer and marcus simeon
just said okay i can turn that around
like it's a bp basketball just like that
the blue jays who never shut it down
have a chance to get back into this game
with one swing here's guriel his second
at bat of the day
[Applause]
and he lines one softly into right for a
base hit
biggio had to make sure it was getting
through he'll stop at third and the
bases are loaded so now all the runners
get a head start vizio from third
espinal from second and most importantly
guriel from first in case simeon hits
one in the gap there they go and the 3-2
up and away ball four that'll force in a
run and make it seven to five
and get beshette to the plate
and brandon hyde's seen enough and tyler
wells comes on to try to get that last
out for the orioles he faces
with the bases loaded two down seven
five one two again
and it's in the air shallow right down
the line and dropping
and two runs have scored a bloop single
for bushette has tied the game at seven
the outfield was deep
they didn't need to be deep they needed
to play straight up
so they could catch this tough slider
that he hits off the end of the bat and
sometime deer has a long way to come
quincy has it he dives no it's not going
to happen right off the end of his glove
it's in and it's out wow what a game and
now they've got guerrero up platy one
for four he homered in the first and the
pitch
and he lines it in the left center
and it's going to the fence
simeon will score the [ __ ] around third
he's getting the wave he will score and
it's a two-run double for guerrero a
five-run inning for the blue jays and
they've got a 9-7 lead
so now the blue jays are an out away
leading 10-7 mancini is over three with
a walk
1-1 and a swing and a ground ball to
short simeon's got it on to first and
the losing streak is over
the blue jays score six runs in the
ninth inning romano finishes it off
buchette guerrero simeon and company
beat the orioles tabby by a score of 10
to seven